well the thing with California too is
California has decided that they have no
obligation to follow the laws of any
other state that's correct so if if
by some miracle you ended up
um having a Texas Court say that your
sons should come back from California
California would refuse of their own law
they won't send them back
um the they they are obligated by law to
give my son gender affirming Health Care
they have to give it to them
and a judge can consent without either
parent consenting a judge can consent
that's a Scott weiner yep state senator
Scott weiner do you do you know if
they've begun any medical procedures
chemical or no because I don't get any
information so she's been there since
end of December and I have no
information on my son at this point it's
just this is a federal we need the
federal government to step in I I the
only issue with the federal government
stepping in is you have the president of
the United States who is in favor of
child sex changes